today is a really big day for me yes i'm
going to be proposing yes to my
girlfriend fine so it's really important
for me that this day goes perfectly
because i want my girlfriend elena to
remember it forever the whole reason we
came to turkey was to get married but i
had always been hesitant to commit and
now
we've been through a lot of hard things
together a lot of hard things that
are because of my behavior
and her faith in me really assures me
that she's the girl i want to be with
forever
because who else would believe in me
like that
[Music]
i think the plan is once when we get to
the waterfall
me and my girlfriend will like walk wow
up the stairs yes and then we'll be on
top of the boat okay and that's when
i'll play the piano for her fine and
then after i play the piano okay that's
when i'm gonna
ask the question
so yeah make sure you keep it a secret
don't tell her
keep it a secret okay okay
oh i'm so nervous i'm hungry also
this
proposal involves a lot of surprises
i want it to be
romantic i want it to be memorable i
wanted to be majestic and i wanted to
show that
i
am worthy of her forgiveness
i've rented a keyboard piano
and i have been hiding my engagement
ring from arlena in a sock in my
suitcase the whole time
i wanted to make sure that i felt ready
to give it to her and it feels like
a milestone of each it feels like i just
got to the peak of the mountain and now
i'm looking at the valley
so
oh
[Music]
i'm really nervous this is my first time
ever writing a song and i'm going to be
performing it on one of the biggest day
of our lives so hopefully
i don't joke
hello
oh hey captain hello how are you doing
good do you want to do a practice and
then you can pretend to be alina yeah
okay here okay i'll play for you you can
sit on the table there ready ready
[Music]
will you marry me
whoa fine that's
a good thing
do you think she will say yes
[Music]
you